what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
um i'm going to be reacting to
top 21 tick tock mgtow truths
why men start a date stopped dating
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
um while you're at it go follow my
instagram it's just pearly things
with a z um that is just pearly things
with a z
okay
new trend show a picture of your
boyfriend holding a fish then a picture
of him and you
this is him holding a slimy dead thing
and this is him holding the love of his
life
[Music]
tens of thousands let's agree to
disagree right now
okay because i know we're gonna do it
see you may have the tens of thousands
of women
but i have the tens of thousands of men
what the women aren't telling you is how
toxic they were to them
how all the time they were never [ __ ]
good enough no matter how hard they
worked
but they got up and went to work when
she didn't and when they tried to escape
reality by getting on their xbox for a
few minutes
oh it was a problem he wasn't allowed to
have his own life
he was a prisoner in his marriage but he
would have dealt with it for more years
to come
because he loves his wife and kids and
he knows as soon as that secret divorce
was
forced on him he would lose everything
even his kids
what you don't see sir is the injustice
that's happening
behind a lot of those women that are
power tripping
well he's gonna do what i want or i'm
gonna get divorced and take the kids
you know what happens to a lot of those
men they go home to their empty homes
and commit suicide they were never ever
good enough
think about it for a minute no that's
true
men are not represented fairly in
divorce court they're really not
now oh god not the dog
not the dog i will probably never pay
off my student debt
but i would have sex with a guy if he
paid off my student loans
like i would never sleep my way to the
top but i would for sure sleep my way to
breaking even
okay what
oh do not understand why the question
when dating is always can you cook
is if that's the only thing a woman can
and should know how to do i'm about to
start asking these men can you fix a
leak
do you know how to change a flat tire do
you know how to build a house sir can
you grill
okay i do agree with that if if your
requirement for women is that she can
cook and clean
i do agree that then women have a right
to ask you
that sort of thing or can you pay for
someone to do that
oh you oh wait what
let's go oh dear oh
stop this is how
we solve all of you i do not like call
her daddy
i think they're talk problems he didn't
text me back
you have a full roster okay
you line them up he ditches you you grab
the next and the next and the next
see i don't think women are really meant
to do
that i just can't imagine uh
i don't like that so i'm talking to this
girl on tinder and we're actually having
a really good conversation
and so we decided to meet up and i know
you shouldn't meet up for like nice
dinners but it was going well and she
wanted to try this new place so i was
like
you know what i'ma just do it so we go
there and
she shows up with like a guy and i'm
like what
what's up like who's this your
interpreter like what the [ __ ]
and she's like oh like this is my date
and i'm bamboozled because i'm like i'm
your date
and she goes well i wanted it to be like
a three-way kind of thing and i'm like
what the heck and i'm just not the kind
of person that like can just get up and
leave
when i'm already like in front of
someone so i stayed through the dinner
it was very awkward she thought we were
both gonna like date her and be her
boyfriend at the same time and
at the end she like hands me the check
and she's like do you just want to grab
this
what this is the put a finger down
hoe edition put a finger down if you've
been in more than 10 relationships
put another finger down if you've been
in more than four relationships in the
last year put a finger down
if you've left someone you're dating to
date someone else
put a finger down if your body count is
over five
put a finger down if you've texted more
than three people at once or talked to
more than three people at once
put a finger down if you've sent the
same message to at least two people
put a finger down if you've dated your
ex's best friend
put a finger down if you've moved on in
less than a week
put a finger down if you've dated
someone that your friend liked
put a finger down if you have a spot
that you bring dates
and then put a finger down if you've
kissed more than two people in 24 hours
oh dear
so i never understood why girls
like gang bangers and drug dealers but i
think i grew up pretty different than a
lot of people on a woman's neck
feminism is women asking that the boot
be removed
men's rights activists think that having
to take their boot off a woman's neck
is some sort of reverse oppression
that's okay that is not true
that is not true okay and i'm not even
completely
against feminism but you have to admit
that
feminism goes too far in some aspects
uh for example
paternity tests should be mandated at
birth
men should have adequate rights in court
there's a lot of
problems that men have that women really
don't sympathize with conservatives
figure that there was never a problem
with the boot being on the neck until
the woman started complaining about it
and if everybody would just shut the
[ __ ] up things would be fine
good guys take any complaint about the
boot
as a personal attack because not all men
wear boots
male allies try to discuss the issue
what if guys just openly said
women are [ __ ] and
women were like well not all women are
[ __ ]
you know what i mean it's it's the same
same way
without alienating the boot
women with internalized misogyny don't
know why these other women are
complaining about the boot on their neck
they love having the boot on their neck
and there's something wrong with the
women who complain
meanwhile the boot stays on the [ __ ]
neck
wow that's another thing men can
literally just get accused
so it was finally time to put the spy
camera i bought to the test and try to
catch my girlfriend cheating
it looks just like a normal charger it's
pretty realistic so pretty happy with
that
i decided to set it up right here so i
could see if anyone came into our room
at night
and yep um from an angle you can't
really see the camera at all so that's
pretty great
it's pretty much invisible i'm going to
leave the house now for a couple days
until i'm going to go to my friend's
house and
i'm going to see what she does
a while after we got a notification from
the app that there was motion detected
in the camera
and when we looked at the live stream we
could see someone's feet on the top left
part of the screen
it's definitely not her feet they're way
too big that's 100 another guy
i ran home to kick this other guy out of
my house and literally
she locked me out this girl literally
locked him out of my own house when she
has another guy over
[Music]
i actually have that one
i just moved in next door i'm a
supermodel
i don't care who the irs sends i am not
paying taxes
okay half the time though
these guys like they'll take you out to
dinner all the time
and then you get fab
it's not an excuse but kind of a little
bit if your fiance is at a bachelor
party
in florida at ages and his name is nate
he came up to us out of the blue
truck to tell us that he would take a
bullet for you
he would fight for any man for you and
you were made for him
i just want you to know girl that's so
cute
congratulations
want to know a sad hollywood tragedy
this is the life of brandon frazier
he was one of the biggest names in
hollywood in the 90s he did movies such
as
george in the jungle and of course the
mummy trilogy and many many more the
future was looking bright for frasier
and everyone was waiting for his
upcoming movies
after an award-winning performance in
the movie crash he slowly began to fade
away
and he took a break for two years
everyone was surprised when he made a
comeback
but here's the thing he didn't look the
same he made a drastic change in his
appearance and everyone was noticing
this
and his movies weren't doing so well so
what really happened in those two years
turns out it wasn't just a bad day but
rough rough years with his marriage
after 10 years the couple decided to
divorce but it wasn't pretty
after the couple slit afton smith
brandon frazier's wife
won an alimony of nine hundred thousand
dollars a month
but here's the thing brandon wasn't
getting the same gigs and he couldn't
afford this
after stated he's hiding his earning to
reduce a monthly alimony during this
time he also lost his mom
now the actor's trying to get his life
back and get more gigs pray for him guys
oh
gosh a million a month for existing
that's insane
so i just received a letter in the mail
from my county's friend of the court
my daughter's mother has
taken the five phone calls i get a week
down to three phone calls
a week to tell my daughter good night
i don't understand why dads don't have
rights
dads don't have a leg to stand on i
don't understand
how a phone call good night can hurt
anything i just wish that the mothers
that do this kind of thing would realize
that the damage that they're causing
onto their kids
is far greater than the spite that they
should have for
their ex if i'm on your for you page
you're not on straight tick tock but
you're not an alt tick tock
you're on daddy and mommy issues tick
tock so how is your hypersexuality
codependency and self-esteem issues
going also which mental illnesses do you
have
wow
this is this is a
i'm so awkward sometimes i don't even
know what to say to some of this stuff
like ah
ah you know sorry about that
um okay but some of these are actually
pretty messed up
um but let me know in the comments what
you guys agree with or you disagree
um whatever your thoughts are don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell
and follow my instagram guys
just pearly things with the z i will
talk to you guys next time